what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch The Last
of Us episode 7 today of course Joe and
by my great friend over here Andrew
Gordon Igor 7-Eleven
I thought that coconut water sorry about
that man I just got this from The Tipsy
bison had a bigot sandwich so yeah I'm
just chilling anyway guys make sure to
go ahead and leave a lock and after that
subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next episode is up here on this
Channel full length Ranch and watch
alongs where you sync up with your own
copy of The Last of Us available for our
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
cover a bunch of stuff exclusively over
there also wanted to announce the real
rejects got themselves an exclusive Last
of Us inspired t-shirt take a look at
that you can get it at
shopzeroedition.com it's inspired by
that Sean of the dead end couldn't have
Ellie turn into a clicker because that
just wouldn't make any sense don't worry
this scene is not in the game or the
show it would be stupid if it was but
it's an awesome t-shirt that I'm proud
we have here at the rejection Andrew you
ready to presumably see Riley finally in
the show Tommy I am or was that Nicholas
Cage from Ghost Rider I don't know but
yes I am ready to see Riley uh it's been
a major anticipation of mine let's do it
let's do it
oh [__] Dragon yep yep guess we're
skipping over that whole left behind
stuff at least the mall part probably I
don't know yes we'll find we'll find out
leave shut up John be good Joe shut the
[__]
go she's cool
oh
[Music]
flashback flashback yeah flashbacks
we're doing flashbacks
training fedra training well we've never
seen any of this they did mention the
Walkman in the DLC
wow you don't fight your friend fights
she's not here anymore
[Music]
must be that Gap when Riley wasn't
around you've never been when I called
well behaved but the last few weeks
don't look at my family
Bethany's in the infirmary with 15
stitches good okay damn
15 seconds
take [__] orders from your patrol leader
will probably be Bethany
there's the other path follow the rules
you become an officer
when you're an officer you get to tell
the bethanies of the world exactly where
to shove it
guys a fast talker if we go down the
people in this Zone will starve or
murder each other that much I know
which we've seen in other zones
there's a leader in you
and one day it could be your turn
so which way
take his keys keys
good let's grab him let's grab him
ah dinosaurs
no pun intended
survive and endure
endurance survive sorry sorry I know I'm
so dumb
it's so cool to actually see it opened
up and being red
combat two
damn Riley
hang up on me like that it was a joke
hey I thought it would work better
terrible jokes are you okay I'm fine I
just ran away for a bit that's all if
you're going through some [__] you're
supposed to I don't know your best
friend about it
wait who gave you the black eye tell me
where you were give me a name and I'll
[__] them up it was Bethany and I
already [__]
I joined the Firefly oh [__] you
I will tell you everything first you
have to promise me something sort of
crazy and you're gonna say no but then
you have to say yes very perfect casting
on Riley
come with me for a few hours and have
the best night of your life
oh yeah
I mean if you get dressed
I like the revamp on having there be
more of an intense reaction to her join
the fireflies so where are we going
secret you trust me right
I don't know should I trust you of
course you should with your life
guards no
dispatch or something stupid
ready this better be good
I didn't have a black eye right I don't
believe she had a black guy in the game
at this part yeah you put Carol in the
infirmary for a [__] week I'm just
saying you can't fight everything and
everyone you can pick and choose what's
important good lesson are they teaching
you this at Firefly University
Carol
[__] Carol
it really is the best
see oh Firefly lights are better
that's why you gotta join
okay I'm sorry
two floors [__] you that cardio and
I've been off
oh [__] right no no this this guy wasn't
here yesterday
yikes that's scary
how disgusting
it's the drink this guy must have spent
every card he had to get this no one
told one Tom can mix pills with that
[__] uh
scary
if
yum give me accept or reject the drink
it's great
I should hold it down can I hold your
gun
kind of made me swear not to let other
people handle this I don't want to
handle my sidearm because I'm such a
[__] Firefly
[Laughter]
okay
um one night you were in the hole I got
bored so I snuck out I was on my way
back being stealthy stealth and this
chick popped out of nowhere chick like
all right no like 40 or 50.
she said she was impressed watching me
sneak around
and she asked what I thought about fedra
so I told her the truth their fascistic
bags no word initiations nope I said yes
and now I'm a firefly congratulations as
much as I love arguing with your
stubborn ass
we're on a mission here
[Music]
fun rooftop Adventure today
waking up everyone there
oh my God Matrix leaps
you know I'll begin the [__] yeah so
you don't bomb stuff anymore
now when civilians are around that began
to push
[__] it's okay you don't know
and two right here
is it gonna be it
it is there the mall it's full of
infected it gets sealed off then why
isn't it sealed off
logical questions
[Music]
so much careless noise just slamming
around
they've been really loud all episode
turns out when Federer connected that
block up to the grid this place got
connected too
[Music]
circuit breaker turn right open the door
tell me when
[Music]
I'd be so afraid if I was Ellie right
yeah now what
[Music]
fun
wow holy [__]
damn
[Music]
wait the lights were fine you saw
outside it's like a big bunker no one
can see [__] but us
and you ain't seen nothing yet
tonight I'm gonna show you the four
wonders of them all
no way
electric stairs
escalator escalator
go away
experience the joy
this was our reaction the first time we
experienced an escalator
uh yeah sure
this is the first Wonder oh [__]
it's cool they're playing this song this
song in the second game yeah
dawn of the Wolf
and the outbreak happened
people started looting stuff that's gone
is the stuff that people need it the
most
wanted I guess toilet paper
[Laughter]
I mean I don't get why people back then
wanted all this stuff do you need me to
explain it to you it looks uncomfortable
imagine it is I know firsthand what
nothing I was just trying to imagine you
wearing that shut up
foreign
go ahead put it on for Riley
I'm on my way so you guys have made so
much noise it wouldn't have mattered if
you broke the window at this point I
think she was just making sure she
looked good for her this is where HBO
got all their sponsorships to fund this
product placement do you trust me with
my life apparently oh well then give me
your hand
come on Walker to an arcade
[Music]
oh
yes
[__]
hopefully she never saw face off
what no way yeah
[Music]
you're a drunk
I
remember them drinking this much
[Music]
oh
word
[Music]
no
oh
like this tone poem like stepping into a
independent movie
oh a clicker turn it off
they know how to operate merry-go-rounds
you know we can make things better
could be running things
you
could be running things that earlier
scene does complement this better you
know what Quang gave me
sewage detail
standing guard while people shovel [__]
what they think of me
what you know you're the one thing I
miss from that [__] place
if that makes a difference
no
we're two wonders down three more to go
I want a magic chorus with like a
million lights I don't know how it's
supposed to get better oh there's ways
the photo booth is that a time machine
foreign
[Music]
to Facebook like in the game
[Laughter]
idiot I was waiting to do it with you
it's expensive five bucks for pictures
um
okay bunny ears wait
back to back yeah
uh just scary
this was us at Greg's wedding
[Music]
that one's not bad okay they did get him
sweet
and they didn't have to break it listen
yes
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
laughs
Mortal Kombat 2 we want to see it
Daytona
[Music]
it's great you can't even play once
I actually get to play you [__] yeah
same [__] that spent an hour
yesterday breaking this [__] open she
thought of everything
[Music]
there it is
how many times I played that game on
SNES
[Music]
is going to be Molina yep remember she
called that earlier in the other episode
[Music]
do the fatality
fatality
[Music]
I could never do a fatality for the life
of me
been here a few times
don't wait to do everything with me
[Music]
yikes oh no
wow just from The Sound that's four down
dude
[Music]
oh
come on next thing oh she really wanted
to kiss her uh it's getting late I just
can't get in trouble again
about you here tomorrow
um
I got you a gift
honey I do like gifts is it a spider no
is it in your shirt no is it a water
pistol it's better better is that
dinosaur possible oh did you get that
reference yeah oh wait wait
is it tacos I understood that one too
oh
so much fun spoilery in there
volume two there it is
what did the frustrated cannibal do
laid on me he threw up his hands
what did the triangle say to the circle
so pointless
how does a computer get drunk it takes
screenshots
what are screenshots I don't actually
know release the Extended Cut oh here we
go what do you call an alligator in a
so uh five bumps we would never use them
on you or anywhere ever near you I would
never let them do that do you never let
them let them yeah I mean I guess we'll
find out
Ellie it's okay I'm going Ellie
Ellie
none of this [__] was even about me
would you stop Q Ellie
Ellie I'm leaving wow they're sending me
to a post in the Atlantic cutesy
good reaction
I asked if you could
Charlene said no
no Marlene is the lady that helped me
get it doesn't matter
why did you bring me here because I
wanted to see you
[Music]
I wanted to say goodbye
listen easy Ellie it actually is
you just did
it
I have some bras and underwear on the
way out
it's got way scarier I know
oh are we getting the right way
is it gonna be the store
oh yes Halloween store
right
the fifth Wonder
I thought you'd like this from the best
and we saved it for last
I guess I was stupid
I don't know what it was like to have a
family I didn't have them for long but I
had them I belonged to them and I want
that again ah maybe the fireflies aren't
what I think they are but they chose me
okay I matter to them you matter to me
first
goddamn I wanna punch you so bad
it makes you hate me less
you're my best friend and I'll miss you
well
mate's not over yet
one last thing
[Music]
what am I supposed to do with this put
it on stupid why I plug it in
you little thief I was definitely
um probably gonna get it the exact same
masks too I love it yeah
yeah same song
give us a roar Ellie oh come on give us
a real Roar
it's so crazy
I feel like I'm watching a Natural Born
Killers
hahaha
wow you can feel all the emotions still
yeah
oh
I'm sorry
it's worth so me
what do we do now we're gonna figure it
out
get ready to run
oh
my God whoa
there she's just knocked out what
get him Ellie
oh it's so creepy
[Music]
oh [__] yeah
yeah
way to go Ellie
teamwork just took one
holy [__]
oh
must be your first
[Music]
no no no no no no no no
no no oh
[Music]
wow
what
even a cold cut
geez
it's like I am not ending up alone again
can't lose another one
[Music]
she's searching for supplies I love it
wait I see you without two options you
take the easy way out no I don't like
option one
this way for everyone sooner or later
right somewhere but we don't quit we
don't give that up
I don't want to give that up
create these last memories I could just
be a poetic and [__] and lose our minds
together
what's option three
sorry I'm sorry
thank you
stitches
oh that's like the structure of the
parallel in here
[Music]
the
that's really nasty
ouch
[Music]
that was so painful
Ellie Rising ooh Daddy
what'd you think uh yeah I really
enjoyed it I mean it definitely was a
little bit of a slow burn at the
beginning uh in terms of uh Riley and
Ellie when they were starting off their
journey and they were being Extremely
Loud
they were supposed to be extremely
silent
Island but uh no one's like jumping
rooftops and talking very loudly
um but aside from from that nitpick I
had once it like they got into the mall
area like you know I I like some of the
changes that they made from the game
like actually seeing them get to play
the video games and some of this stuff
and then some of the expansions that
they made
um you know from the game I I thought
were really well done if you guys
haven't played the game it's the is it
DLC it's the DLC yeah but it's a hundred
percent
important for the complete package it's
not just like extra fun adventure for
you like it definitely there's a reason
they made sure to adapt it yeah and also
to the location where Joel is when she's
having this flashback memory like
they're in a mullet uh or it's I I don't
know if they're in a mall but they're
right near where the University of
Eastern Colorado they were not in a
house when she's having this flashback
so that was a different that was that
was a different yeah it was a mall too
well I mean beyond that it's they the
fun the thing about it though is for
most of the DLC you are doing what
they're doing yeah you're actually like
killing infected or anything you're just
doing the actual [__] here yeah yeah I
was just talking about the location with
uh Joel Nelly but I think the thing I
love so much about that DLC in this is
there's dramatic irony you know we is
you know we as we as an audience we we
know like what's gonna happen because
it's a flashback whereas the characters
don't but it's still it's very effective
and I think that's where dramatic irony
like is can be very effective and I just
think it was written so well in the game
and it's really done well and executed
here and I thought that actress that the
guy who played Riley I'm sorry that I
don't know her name right now she did a
fantastic job I mean the way like after
they they got bitten and you know the
way how she was really emoting and you
could see her crying like I mean I
really felt that so much so it was great
I mean the game she was definitely
obviously she was really sad and
emotional too in that in those moments
but I really felt it a lot too uh here
and I I love so many the the Easter eggs
and stuff that obviously when we get to
Paul's video into the theory time in
spoiler talk we'll we'll get into uh a
lot of the stuff that I want to talk
about more in depth that I'm not going
to but overall it was a pretty good
episode I wouldn't call it one of my
favorite episodes I would say more in in
the mid-tier OR such but aside from
again some nitpicky stuff I had I
enjoyed it I thought you know the
relationship between Ellie and Riley was
pretty well fleshed out again you can't
make it obviously as long as it was in
the DLC but given the time frame that we
did have I thought it was pretty
effective for the most part and you know
I thought it was pretty good what about
you yeah I thought it was pretty good
too
um I think there's a lot to that this is
funny enough
you know
um
this is one of the harder ones well most
I can do is just be honest this is one
of the harder ones for me to not compare
to the game only because it's really
short in the game like comparatively
speaking it's like yeah you can like
complete it like an hour and a half it's
not that long
um specifically the Riley part the
flashback as well because because in the
in the game she's looking for supplies
for Joel and having to deal with Raiders
and hunters and stuff but and some
Infected as well but the stuff that just
focuses solely on Riley like that's
that's pretty short and so this was the
one where I did find myself like really
impressed with a lot of how they brought
it to life and so even when I say
compare I don't even mean that in a
negative context it's just there's a lot
where you're like oh wow that that is
what impresses me the most is when they
do dramatic scenes like when they are
sitting down together and they're
talking about their two options
and wow this is crazy they are nailing
the emotion the tears everything
and like the game and so you have this
thought process going off where uh well
at least for me when I'm watching it
like wow that is so much like what I
played and and saw more amazed and
sometimes I'm not as
this can be the I don't know I'm not the
only one I know this is not I know some
people have played the game and they can
easily just get completely wrapped up in
it and still be so emotionally
enthralled uh with just with the emotion
of what the episode's trying to do I can
sometimes be in the other side of the
camp of people who played the game where
I am
I I have an awareness going on of do you
know what I mean like you have that
awareness of that is like the game and
you're watching and you're watching it
so there's I'm like
70 emotion and 30 I'm aware of I'm
seeing I'm I'm also seeing the cut scene
in the game while I'm watching it you
know and uh as I'd love to be just to
complete opposite camp but you know
that's just a reality of the situation
so I thought they did a an excellent job
with adapting if they got all the The
Essentials now what I thought that they
did it was really neat on a structure
level is because yeah they did they skip
past a bunch in the game that's really
that would have been great to bring your
life 100 000 but for the choice to save
uh Joel and like as a seasoned structure
I am get it a really clickered with me
by the very end of it because you see
Joel lose a daughter and in the last
episode he was dealing with the fact
that he feel like he would be
essentially a handicap a detriment to
Ellie being able to survive and make the
ultimate journey to become the vaccine
right
and then you see them have Henry and Sam
and that [__] goes wrong she even tries
to save Sam but can't so she fails there
and then you get this moment with
um Riley this whole flashback where she
you know like they've both lost they
have both lost their loves both of them
and Joel is now going to be saved by his
daughter his new daughter his surrogate
daughter and Ellie is going to save is
the next person that she loves is Joel
and I think structurally because it's
essentially what the Left Behind thing
is doing in the DLC but for for a tight
50-minute episode I actually think
um structuring it this way was great
because
you experience this loss but there's
also this hopeful catharsis that you get
when she does end up saving him at the
end with doing the stitching and then
him making the choice too like yes I
will live on I will carry on I like that
Joel made that choice along with her
like let me have a shot at do it you
know what I mean definitely well I mean
obviously too there's a major change
because in the game he's for I mean he's
kind of conscious but he's pretty much
he's basically unconscious for the whole
time so I thought that was an
interesting choice but you know also in
the snow and [__] freezing their asses
yeah yeah but I actually I I didn't mind
the change where they had him basically
again just echoing your sentiments what
you just said I I like that because you
know there is that emotional gun punch
that you feel when he does like yes I I
wanna I wanna survive I want to move uh
fight on like because from that moment
he had at the beginning of the episode
where he's like like get away from me
I'm I'm I'm a detriment to you like I I
failed you like and then you know that
moment that he has it's kind of like a
mini Arc in the episode for Joel so I
found some reason he's kind of just
going around aimlessly and then he finds
a reason to live yeah no I I just that's
why I love the change like it's it's a
good payoff to the change I think in
that moment at the end like when you
hear Greg and I like it's give that awe
when they're holding hands like that's
that payoff for me of why they made that
change I'm like okay that's I'm glad
they made that for sure yeah I love the
parallel of you have the whole handing
with Riley what they are saying goodbye
to each other because they both believe
they're gonna die yeah and then you have
a different one where they get to live
so and um yeah I think you know from the
gamer perspective of bringing the mall
to life and everything was awesome
and and uh
uh the what I want to know her name I
think she's the one who plays the sister
in
Zendaya's sister in um that famous show
that I've seen all of euphoria uh I
think I think that's her but I I do want
to know her name because it's bothering
me I feel like I would know it it's not
storm read that's a completely different
actress no I'm thinking of someone else
it is Storm read okay okay you had it
who plays
oh no no that other girl plays Storm an
X-Men apocalypse that's right my mind
was getting confused there all right
yeah I figured it out also too I thought
they had really good chemistry her and
belly and just so everyone knows does he
keep calling her belly yes I've
explained this a thousand times Bella
Ramsay is playing Ellie you combine the
two you get belly okay yeah belly belly
makes sense
um but I thought they had really good
chemistry and there were a couple times
in the DLC that they had some
disagreements but here it got elevated
to a totally different level like where
she's really storms off and then you
know comes back so I was like wow they
uh really like took that to another
level in terms of like them having a
major disagreement and Ellie just being
sorry Belly being so so hurt over
you know uh Riley just going leaving uh
I think she said she was going to
Atlanta the Atlanta QC you're just being
so devastated that you know this her
best friend and also someone who she
obviously is very affectionate towards
is leaving her and like they really I
mean obviously it was a big deal in the
DLC but it's just it's played a lot more
harder here and I like that they
expanded a lot more on that in again
this 50 minute time span so I thought
they uh really again just it really felt
a lot more emotionally gut-wrenching in
terms of when Ellie stormed off and then
she had to come back I mean how'd you
feel about that
how do I feel about that just about them
like expanding like them arguing a
little bit more and her being a little
more again I wouldn't say she's more
devastated but just them bickering and
arguing a little bit more than I felt
like they did in the DLC and did you
feel that way or do you feel I'm well no
no I think they changed the I think they
changed the context around a little bit
here because they didn't have anything
with the pipe bomb was it pipe bomb yeah
I don't remember DLC they didn't have
any of that and they drive home further
in this whole thing too with they gave
me sewage work yes yes like they they
flesh out some other elements where you
see the divide in the path more clear
and I no I did I think for the episode
it totally works
um especially when you're trying to
condense down that the DLC because this
feels like the short shorter film
version of that you know and so I think
when you are trying to condense that
down you do need some some more moments
because it's a little bit more subtle in
the build up to it what are you trying
to say no no okay I'll keep going but
it's a little more subtle on the build
up to it because they're trying to um
because like in the game you you are
seeing her
you're like what's Friday up to you like
why does she want to do this why should
I do this and and Ellie's on to her the
whole time but it takes a while for her
to reveal it and so it's I feel like
it's more solemn in the game you know
what I mean it's kind of it's kind of
got this resonating
sadness throughout in the DLC you know
we're here you are watching it unfold
and when they do escalate into that
blowout
it was
it was it was good it was effective to
me
um because yeah you do kind of
I think when you're free when I was
when you're playing when you're playing
the game it has this interesting effect
where you are just having fun
for a very very long time you are like
clicking the buttons for the photo booth
and going on the Merry-Go-Round and the
water the Super Soakers and then when
they're going through the book it's like
you ask like a gazillion questions and
then in the Halloween store you're
playing with that one item the the was
it was like around the Halloween store
yeah over talks back or oh the the skull
head yes it's like the eight ball where
you would ask questions yes that's what
it was I'm trying to remember what it
was so you're in it for such a long time
but you're in the back of your head
you're going
guys
and yeah the arcade scene I actually
kind of prefer in the game the arcade
scene you know with the with the Turning
where it didn't work and she imagined it
right where she closed her eyes yeah
because you are building the um you were
building their connection throughout and
it I I felt like they really built that
emotion where here due to the fact that
you they just probably have no choice
but to like pare it down like you just
gotta pair it down and it has it has
some different scenes in here that I
think are very
you know wait for John and Terror so
that way they've never played the game
so they're not going to be doing
anything just comparison [__]
um but yeah for for this particular
episode I thought that when it did get
to that moment
I found it to be I don't know it wasn't
as like super I'm trying to think if I
was like super impacted by it but uh uh
I I I I I really notice uh as much as
you did like you seem like you really
took note of it and I'm like I feel like
I've been searching for words but at the
end of the day I'm like I don't really
take much notice of it because I'm like
it's a show I I was curious to see if
they were actually I I didn't think they
were but I was kind of curious just
because there have been changes here and
there expansions and I was kind of
curious if they were going to show Riley
actually turn and then if like does
Ellie have to kill like what did happen
because I don't know like I never read
like I know you know in Wikipedia or
whatever they always have like oh this
is what happens to a character when they
don't show stuff on screen but I was
kind of wondering like what did happen
after Riley turned in like did Ellie
have to kill her did the fireflies have
to kill like what happened I was always
curious about that so I I thought maybe
they were going to show that but either
way it's it doesn't impact like my
enjoyment of this but I did that uh it
was a very interesting addition showing
Ellie in military training and federal
training rather because obviously in the
game we'd only been taught that had only
been a thing that had been talked about
never shown so again getting another
expansion of the video game I thought
that was interesting just seeing you
know ease of her rising to leadership
yeah oh that too of course uh but I just
thought that was again just seeing what
she has to deal with on a daily basis
where I wouldn't say bullying but again
just like
I mean would you call that bullying
because I mean the girl was just really
getting on her more because she wasn't
like hitting her laps and they had to do
double time because of her and all that
but either way she had to deal with some
form of of abuse and she was kind of
feeling lonely without Riley so I you
know I thought again just even though
we're obviously Beyond emotionally
connected to belly at this point just
again just adding another uh sense of
why she doesn't want to end up alone uh
and I just thought again just a really
important expansion showing that and I
thought it was interesting to uh just
circling back to when you know because
obviously Greg and I and all of you who
have played the games you know uh when
you know after they had been bitten she
gives uh well the way I see is we got
two options we can either take the easy
way out or what the the second option
that she says we can go crazy with each
other whatever it was I thought that was
interesting
I thought that was interesting were uh
Captain Kwan or what um you know the
federal guy uh that he was talking he
gave that he just two options gave the
two options too I was thinking that in
the back of my mind when you said that
but again I just I thought that was
really interesting again the expansion
of something that was just talked about
in the video games and then showing like
Ellie and mil and federal training so
I'm glad that they showed that well they
they fleshed out more what the
the war between fedra and fireflies and
the political angles there and choosing
choosing the sides here yeah because
yeah that's not it's really not you know
back to that DLC it's really not about
any of that it's it's more the fact that
Riley's going to be leaving is the is
the is the sad part for it but L.A
doesn't seem super perturbed by the fact
that it's the fireflies you know well in
the video game she knows Marlene like
they have a history with each other
whereas here she has no idea who Marlene
is because we obviously in the first
episode we saw their first scene
together yeah them meeting each other
rather their introduction to each other
so there's a different dynamic as she
really is under the belief that the
fireflies are you know this evil
propaganda machine so it's it adds a
different interesting Dynamic uh you
know and a controversy between the two
of them you know a political Dynamic if
you will I thought their chemistry was
great I thought uh belly uh absolutely
what does that mean explain in the
comments I thought belly absolutely
killed did I thought she was great she
she felt
she does have this sometimes she does
have that Bell around sometimes does
have this uncanny ability with her
delivery where I'm like sounds just like
her yeah there are moments and I did
like seeing the the pain and the the
horror that comes with
when she is when she is bit because she
has no idea that she's immune you know
it's like she they feel like their lives
are about to end it's it's such a it's
such a mean sometimes the world The Last
of Us can't be very mean it is like I
remember when I played the dlz and then
the way the kiss went down and was like
don't go kisses okay like she agrees not
to go then and then the second half and
I remember like crying when I'm playing
the game like at that moment because I
got hit with they're about to kill her
off her yeah it's such a mean like the
[__] with Henry and Sam and that's what
I mean by dramatic irony like we as the
audience we know what's about to happen
whereas the characters don't but it's
still like is so effective yeah the the
the world of Last of Us and Neil
druckman and Company often have a habit
of going and something that our choice
is to make with this show sometimes see
where they're like how can we make this
sadder make Sam deaf like they just
drive it home even harsher every time
and yeah yeah I do I've always found
I've always found her little funny how
mean the last of us can actually go out
of their way to go all right but right
when that comes around then
they're gonna die and it was and uh the
choice to make it one uh is it a stalker
uh yeah it was a stalker it was a
stalker typically not a clicker make it
one stalker versus a horde that you have
to escape through uh I thought
especially if you haven't played the
game does make it more effective because
I mean demonstrates how hard one person
is yeah and this episode in particular
made me go God that makeup must take
[__] forever oh yeah
um
but you know especially if you haven't
played the game you I think it's easier
to get more hopeful that everything's
gonna that everything might have turned
out all right
you know you're where you're watching a
flashback and the the fact that Riley
died in the first episode yeah of course
and also too I mean
they they uh they they showed us The
Horde already you know and what was it
two episodes ago so I I was not
expecting to see another one I I was
expecting maybe to see one or two at
most in this but I got to imagine too
with the amount of viewership that
they've gotten in the season that you
know possibly next season uh which is
not going to be controversial at all uh
that
there's gonna be uh I would imagine that
there's going to be a little bit more
ramped up in terms of the action when it
comes to the the infected but again the
show's not about the infected it's just
it's it's it's partition yeah it's it
they're in the background obviously if
you add if you add that in there great I
mean you're gonna you're gonna get a lot
of people extra excited about those
action sequences of course but I mean
this makes sense in in the in the TV
show this makes sense to just have one
stalker like it's totally totally
understandable to have one yeah
I can't quite put my
I think the only thing I can do that it
can be very honest about and it's just a
sad unfortunate reality of it is
I I can't quite put my finger on what
did not necessarily fully work for me
about this episode
and the sad part is is that it it feel
like it's mainly because because at any
time I have a criticism that's actually
popping in my Noggin I I'm trying to do
the mental work of
yeah but is it just because I'm
comparing it to what the game did
because especially harder when it's so
much like the game yeah yeah and then
and then it could feel like a very
because for the most part it felt like a
shorter version of the DLC that's that's
what it mainly felt like so in my head
and with a video game which the DLC had
played on on a PS5 with like beautiful
graphics and everything
I feel like I've seen a more fleshed out
version already and and this seems like
the shorter version to me like a remake
of it so I find my mind going I thought
the game did it better because I got to
spend more time in everything and so I
have to like check my Noggin on it and I
don't know I know other people I've
definitely talked with plenty of other
people who have gone through it I know
plain other people who've played it who
haven't gone through it so it's kind of
weird to do a reaction and then be like
I feel like I have criticisms but I'm
not I'm doubting my criticism so much
because I feel like it's only because I
played a video game yeah and I'm like I
have really this is the first episode
out of them all
where I I'm super questionable about
would I feel any of these things that
felt like rush to me if you had if I
hadn't played the game you know no it's
understanding do you get where I'm
coming from
I'm really doubting like I don't know if
I should like I don't even know if any
of this is like the valid criticism in
my own head because I I feel like I'm
just comparing it to the extended
version that I thought did it better
yeah no I mean I don't I mean time
comparison Wise It's hard to compare so
uh but I I get where you're coming from
like I said for me not doing the the
game comparison stuff just just my
little nitpicky stuff there were a
couple times where at the beginning when
they're getting to the mall uh again
there were some some of the dialogue I
really enjoyed but it was just it was
dragging a little bit for me personally
you know if it didn't for you great uh
just uh thought it dragged just a little
bit um and again
me being the nitpicker I am I thought
they were being way too loud and I was
going to pull you out of the reality
yeah
they're supposed it's two or three in
the morning and and she's a firefly and
they're sneaking around in a federal
territory yeah so I mean the whole point
is literally to be as silent as possible
and again obviously we need to hear the
dialogue but I'm not saying
Saints but I mean in a volume that's a
little more reasonable than this you
know like it's not a big deal that we're
talking so loud like we're not sneak
just stuff like that but I mean again I
I hear what you're saying I get it
um but do you have any of that issue at
all do you struggle that at all at all I
mean there's times where it's like I
talk to other people who do as well but
I notice you you don't ever seem like
you do I mean there's times but I I
always say this look I got my video game
version I love what they're doing for
sure it's it's not as long as the game
and they can't copy it you know beat for
beat shot for shot everything so it's
it's hard to make a full-on like sure
yeah it's gotta be the exact same thing
but it's it's it's I get where you're
coming from it's it's called The Last of
Us it's the same character so I I get
why like in the back your head like it
was done and executed like this was
fleshed out longer so I get why I'm
gonna my brain is just it I'm trying not
to make a comparison to what I'm so used
to seeing and so used to playing it's
like the length of things
you know like when they like when they
put when they when when the scene like
the scene the reason that the book scene
um like when when the book pop the the
pun book pops up and hear why it's so
awesome for for people at the game is
because of a very memorable scene in the
DLC
and like that like that scene has so
much emotion and all they're doing is
laughing and criticizing the puns and
stuff but it's such an impactful scene
for some reason in the game it's so
impactful and that you really do feel
like you're lost on a night on the town
yeah where here the I didn't ever truly
get lost in uh
in a mood for the night you know yeah
and that's the that was the part of it
that I I felt like uh because it's the
whole thing like I want to show you a
good time but you were suspecting
something else that and they constantly
had this like melancholic undertone and
here it
I I felt like it was like a big uh
because I I don't I can't I don't know
how to formula it's no I get what you're
saying but it's hard to explain but I
think the people who played the video
game like understand what you're saying
too but I think for me the biggest
disappointment I have from this episode
is the pun that they didn't use what did
the cannibal get when he was late to the
party a cold shoulder
that's the one I was most disappointed
that they missed but nah dude I I truly
get where you're coming from like of
course your brain is just naturally used
to we've played the game so many times
so look and the same thing happens for
me and I I try and check myself out like
when it comes to the MCU versus have you
watched uh Earth's Mightiest Heroes yet
or I know you started it but if you out
okay well I started reading the comics
instead okay I mean again I
I think Earth's Mightiest Heroes is
miles above the MCU but MCU is still
phenomenal and I just at some points I
just I check myself out and go you know
what MCU does a good job of its own
thing so I I just got to check myself
out here and just say hey this is a good
thing here too and I still got Myers
Mightiest Heroes and that's a great
thing too so but I get what you're
saying it's it's totally understandable
it's not you doing it on purpose it's
just your brain is so used to from the
game version so it's it's understandable
yeah because I don't even miss the stuff
of
yeah like I I think it's awesome when
Ellie's in the mall and and having to
look for she's just trying to find like
a freaking first aid kit yeah and and
it's it's an adventure and she's really
badass and it's a struggle it's a lot
and it's it's the most exciting part of
the gameplay because you're because
that's when you're actually dealing with
scared that [__] the whole time right
it's really and I can imagine there's a
part of the audience who's like I oh man
they totally skipped over that and to me
that doesn't even bother me that they
skipped over that it's more when I'm
watching something where like most of
this is pretty much scene for scene but
I'm aware of
I'm aware of the fact that yeah there's
there's it's more of the tone that's
missing for me not really the placement
there there is that like the part where
I thought it was most captured was when
they're on the Merry-Go-Round yeah like
that's kind of the underlying mood of
the entire thing that is perfect yeah I
agree with you on the flip side of that
there are times and moments where I'm
like oh my God I'm glad they added that
or there was a timeline oh definitely
that was actually well that was better
that was actually better than the game
so like yeah there can be you know flip
effect to that as well like you know in
the first episode I love that whole
moment where they're explaining what the
quarter steps uh you know brain
infection can be the foreshadowed like
that was great obviously not in the
video game the second episode just uh
where you know the woman is studying and
what it isn't like bomb the whole like
that's not gonna get like lots of stuff
like that that that's not like again it
works both ways so I I get totally what
you're saying and you know there are
times where my my brain is thinking that
like it's not the game but yeah it I
just checked myself out when that
happens and I'm just I think I still
think this is one of if not the best
video game adaptations
yeah yeah we're just we're trying to
find nitpicky things in a pretty damn
perfect show yeah
like uh no slight to the actress's
author amazing they're absolutely
amazing and I like the structure of it
and it was the I mean come on we're
seven episodes in and we've obviously
I'd still give the show like a 99 yeah I
think also too a Greg's trying to
correlate as well is like as a writer
it's not easy like for someone like even
Neil druckman who's the creator and you
know this is his baby yeah one and two
and even Craig
um Mason right Craig Mason uh it's not
easy to condense something down like to
uh you know from an hour and a half in
the video game DLC to like 45 50 minutes
into a TV show and like hit the same you
know effect level like as it was in but
they they get pretty damn close so you
know you give them credit where credit's
due so but I I totally feel where you're
coming from for sure I mean they deal
with time Jump share in interesting ways
because they they cut to the in the
house and it did make me question like
how come no one's like trying to chase
after them
I just I just I'm not even doing like a
game comparison
I feel like they they could have based
off the way the last episode ended I I
thought with the whole blood being all
over the place they left a trail of the
boys I feel like they could have I feel
like
because they only took because only one
person attacked right in the last
episode yeah because yeah but they had
several other people I'm like what was
their mode of transportation they can't
chase after them yeah or they just
camped out there at the University right
so that's like an actual like question
in my head of like okay how come none of
them are chasing after them
um yeah
like I know some game [__] obviously
coming up whatever but I'm but I'm
saying even if like like completely
removing the game yeah I found myself
questioning like no one's chasing them
this is kind of weird that no one's
chasing them right now
um which the DLC does actually fill in
because of the game itself too they yeah
the dude cut too she they're just hit
out there
um but they they do fill that in the DLC
of them chasing but it does make me go
like logically you'd think some of them
would be Jason chasing them right now
right
so yeah all right overall I honestly all
things said I would still give this like
at least an eight out of ten like I I
know I I know it sounds like I had a
major qualm with it but like I said I'm
I'm really like no I mean what they
brought to life they did really yeah I
just I I feel like they there's this is
great I just think there's a this
episode made me Hyper aware there's a
much greater version of this in my
living room waiting to be played uh and
and that was basically that where but no
other episode really uh kind of evoked
that for me so 8 out of ten you hated it
yeah yeah and I might have put a little
I'm really looking forward to this
episode in particular too and uh maybe
there was a bit of over expectation yeah
of delivering like just uh that drama
down because yeah like the like the mood
of there's a reason I prefer the whole
thing whether
it's like just imagine it with the
arcade game The Turning yeah yeah like
that that that enhances the romance
between them you know yeah
are you say fatalities don't enhance the
romance come on fatalities dude
do you know how many people have bonded
over fatalities yeah in the arcade I
like when they had more time to like
simmer in their um and their romantic
connection because that kind of just
builds in the game you know yeah I think
there's something there it just keeps
getting bigger and bigger yeah and I
think the the crescendo to the kiss
is is much more felt than in here
so I could have just said that 15
minutes ago and I think I would have
easily uh alleviated my what I was
trying to say all righty guys well leave
your thoughts down below subscribe leave
a like and uh
Ricardo Martinez Ricardo my friend I am
so happy you've been part of our patreon
page for such a long time now we're in
2023 and you know what dude from
everything you've ever told us about
yourself which is primarily that you are
Latino I want to know a little bit more
about you so when you see this shot and
I know one day you will I'm expecting a
message in my patreon inbox telling me
some fun details about yourself I want
you to answer these five questions for
me one what is your favorite color ice
cream two what would you say is the most
inspirational film you've ever seen
three tell me about your most traumatic
experience in one sentence four how many
girls or guys have you been with five
what's your favorite show you're
currently watching I want you to answer
all five of them one sentence only
please do not do more than that or else
it's going to be so much response I'm
gonna have to do so Ricardo thank you
for being part of here but it's time to
know more about you other than your
general ethnicity that you uh you know
subscribe to
that you chose to be a part of
[Music]